i got your picture the way you said it
i got your picture
welcome back guys to another episode of
big mood plus the bonus is a bonus the
bonus the bonus
that's why we're so cozy because this is
a bonus the bone is cozy that's how you
know
notice that we changed clothes yeah
nikki really wants us i need you to
notice i think he really wants you to
know this and jess
really wants you to know that nikki
really wants you to
just hates it she really hates it i'm
being passive aggressive sorry
okay at least you're passive aggressive
and cozy
yeah yeah in our bonus episode welcome
back
it's our bonus episode that means we're
going to be answering questions that you
guys have seen
so why are you jealous why are you
jealous i am jealous
like i just want to tell her that i want
to hang out afterwards that's all
matching too but just different colors
oh cute oh yes um so we went on
instagram and we told you guys to ask us
any question for a chance to a shout out
so uh we're gonna answer your questions
today
thanks for asking questions i said
questions a lot can i get a dollar for
every time i
i say that word that's a lot of money
that's that's a lot of dollars
that's easy money question questions
there's a there's a radio show that does
that if you say uh like a certain word
like a [ __ ]
about is every time they have someone
like phone in and ask a question
i think it was like the the loved one
with the doc dr drew one
every time they'd say basically they'd
they'd ring like the that's hilarious
yeah another word is actually like i
actually even noticed literally if you
actually
you know yeah or like it's obviously the
worst yeah i say like
probably ten times a minute that's true
same yeah
all right so the first question is it's
actually from one of my viewers on my
stream that's why she's asking this okay
roseanne and i love her calm down her
name is roseanne
um hi roseanne this is a question that i
always ask that's a name
why are you shocked are you just
picturing like an older white woman on
tv
i'm like you only know roseanne barr
people actually name their child
roseanne
you know rosanna pacino no oh yeah i
only know roseanne barks
she makes baking she's just nerdy
nummies rosanna
yeah that's cute that's cute okay i
think roseanne is cute
too sorry i deserve to be hit somebody
was jess you know we're gonna give her a
shot or something
come punch me so this is a fun question
i always ask to determine if people are
[ __ ] liars or not
whoa um and chat i mean chat sorry i'm
talking to get to my stream sorry
comments feel free to answer this too
okay now
listen to the whole question would you
or would you not
accept this every morning this is the
alarm clock question
okay um every morning you wake up and
you get to set an alarm clock whatever
time you want okay so it's just like a
regular alarm clock except this alarm
clock is a man that pees on you yeah
ew all right okay and some people like
that keep going and he's not like a
gross dude he's just like a regular dude
you know just like maybe like a hot dog
would i want to have sex with him is it
shallow it's just like a butler oh
it's just like a butler think of like
you know um alfred i have a butt back
oh he's in this world okay well well
he's just like a regular dude is he 70
though
no maybe like his 60s okay he's not the
same thing
like he's not like creepy he's not broke
he's not 70.
like 60. he draws a line so he's not
like creepy
sounds like a porno he's not dirty he
wakes you up by peeing on you every
morning
he will kind of aim for the face but he
will like upper area here good for him
for still having a pee stream sometimes
it's hard for them yeah prostate
right now like a sprinkler it's like
come on come on now
once you wake up he stops and then when
you go to the bathroom to shower
he replaces your mattress with a new one
replaces your sheets replaces your
clothes and leaves a couple
dollars oh on your counter every day
sign
a thousand dollars every day i get peed
on every day for a thousand bucks thank
you yes right would you take that yes
hell yeah
yes who says no to them yeah yeah dirty
[ __ ] liars
that's what i'm saying that's how i
figure out who's a [ __ ] liar yeah who
are you to turn down 365 thousand
dollars a year
just to be peed on every morning yeah
it's not even bad people he's like um
not it's poisonous as long as your dick
hole isn't too dirty the pee comes out
sterile
is this butler courteous and i should
not eat
asparagus the night before oh he just
has a regular diet he can eat whatever
he wants
whatever he wants yeah because at least
you know it'd be nice if he didn't
honestly i'd even take chlamydia p for
365
000. i draw the line healable it's
curable it's curable it's wearable it's
curable with
antibiotics i'm not trying to for 300
and about 65
000 i got chlamydia for free in college
okay
i will take it for 365 000. i would even
ask that
so you'd voluntarily get it for that but
she was just offering it without
yeah i mean you go
she has the soldier smile all right how
much i want 365
000 just for waking up every morning i
wanted
so bad i need 365 000 and some people
in my chat usually dudes are like i
would never do that bro i'm like yes you
[ __ ] would
if the money was right in front of you
yeah is it still a dude for them too or
is it
okay and here's the thing is that butler
goes with you everywhere
doesn't matter if you're in a hotel in
another country he's gonna be there it
doesn't matter if you brought a girl
home you just have to explain her like
yo dude this is what's gonna happen
we're both getting peed on in the
morning we're married and
steve gets peed on too like is that
double no you just
you know this is your deal all right
yeah yeah i'm sorry still
pretty good but like and if it was me i
wouldn't want to date someone who
doesn't understand like [ __ ] this is
365k
yeah it's business yeah this is business
this is a transaction right
it's a 10 minute transaction not even
because the moment you wake up he stops
so if you think you got to you know
carry the pee into the bathroom and take
a shower anyway you might be really good
at pinching it closed i wouldn't
but if i got peed on i would yeah moment
you're really tired or hungover or
something he's just gonna keep peeing
until you get out of bed
yeah that sucks i'm pretty good at
waking those are two different things
getting out of bed
or waking up yeah you gotta get out of
bed can you change the time of the alarm
every day or any time you want this oh
yeah
but the moment you tell him like dude i
don't want to do this anymore even one
day even taking a break he will go away
forever
no breaks hmm this is roseanne's
question
no this was my question but rosanna
asked can you ask him a question you
always ask people on stream
oh yeah so that is her question
basically
yeah i would do it i'm really [ __ ]
dedicated like i'm very disciplined and
i feel like
waking up is not that hard for me and
waking up to pee i mean my cat pees on
me
and what has wiggly for free yeah for
free and i had to clean that [ __ ] yeah
like mattress no no yeah yeah i don't
get a new
new mattress i didn't get a thousand but
in fact i had to spend 500
at the vet to find out if you had some
sort of kidney problem turns out
no he's just an [ __ ] yeah
this guy's totally healthy he just pays
you a thousand dollars this is a win-win
situation i can't imagine someone saying
that yeah that's what i'm saying we need
to ask this question to anyone trying to
enter our friend group
because i don't want any [ __ ] liars
yeah right yeah can we ask
all our guests this question for you yes
yeah because i do this all my guess on
streams okay let's just
up the annie five thousand dollar day a
day
he poo poo's on your chest it's not
sexual is it runny
it's not runny it's just a regular poo
poo he's a healthy dude just like a log
no really for five grand cause somebody
what's five times 365 i just feel like i
could get by with 365 000 a year and i
don't really need it actually i'm not
that greedy yeah
i kind of i kind of want to know [ __ ]
that is 1.8 million
dollars oh yeah we're doing it no give
me that [ __ ]
daddy i'm ready for it right
and it's not even gross
a business woman yeah she knows what she
wrote about that i live in a lower
lower status paper with my 365 a year
yeah we're fine we're good i'll [ __ ] on
you
1.8 million all right
so now that we got that out of the way i
just really need to know that so now i
know that you girls are not liars
anyone that you know how depraved it's i
think it goes in this direction
yeah at least depraved you know a little
bit less very
it's a lot yeah just a lot on this couch
actually sure that's the depraved couch
so anyone in the comments that says no
you're a [ __ ] liar and i hope you
realize that well if anyone wants to
like actually do
challenges let me know yeah oh my god
taking applications i am my dams are
open would it be weird for you if it was
more like a sexual thing for them
no i don't care about what it does for
them i care about the money
because for me i'm asking this this is
like a full business thing not even
sexual
well it doesn't matter to you you can
just you're probably doing
no that's in private though i don't
publicly have like vagina pictures all
over the place
i want to be privately public i mean a
private interaction with each
one of your only fans fans
you don't have to post nudes yeah i mean
we can just talk to them
you can talk to them you could post
pictures of feet you could
post pictures it's gonna be weird when i
go to like get a cpa job and then they
google me and they're just like [ __ ]
there already yeah so i hate to break it
to you but you probably have a wicked
feet yeah i mean they're watching
i don't think i think we looked at it
well now you are you know all the creepy
weird [ __ ] is of tiff
is it yeah yeah like like they're
they're always like zooming in on your
tits and your feet and like people are
obsessed with you for some reason
that's true obsessed i'm looking up and
see if she has a wicked feet
no oh you don't wow that's alarming
literally anyone that is associated at
all with
us everyone has one i bet even david and
bart have one if anything probably
yeah holy [ __ ] ew i just remembered when
joe's
whole foot was black and then michael
jordan
and joe had a wart on his f and michael
sucked it on jk party
there was like a flap of black skin
under his foot that was hanging out oh
god i remember never
next question thank you for your your
honesty ladies thank you for that
welcome next question was is from
insomniac jack saying
how was it like living on your own for
the first time i loved it
but i'm a really big introvert homebody
i freaking loved just being able to run
around naked
singing naked with my cats like
doing voices random accents how long did
you laugh
three years oh cool yeah i know
everything was me
like every decoration like i didn't have
to ask anybody what kind of decor i
could put up i just like
made it super girly and it was it was
like girly but like
cool because it had like exposed brick
walls and it was like
in hollywood it had a lot of character
it was a building that the
1920s silent film stars used to stay in
so they
was haunted there was a lot of rape and
murder there was actually energy
i think it was a haunted building but my
place had pretty good energy
maybe like a little starlit living you
bring good energy
oh the scariest part though was in the
bathroom it was all weird like they had
the original icebox in the kitchen and
everything
but in the background you called it an
icebox it was an icebox
um but in the bathroom they had this
steam window
i don't know if you've ever heard of
this no but you open there's a window
in the shower um and it's like a regular
ass window but it's just blackness out
there
because it goes to the middle of the
building and you open the window and it
lets all the steam from the shower out
but if you look in it's just a black
abyss like just a
dark hit and i try to shine a flashlight
to see how far down it goes
i can't see the bottom so i lived on the
second floor
yeah it was really creepy so it's like a
trash chute but for steam
yeah the shower yeah was it like is it
like a dumb waiter kind of
it's just like it was bigger than that
because it was like
um i could see my neighbor's window when
they would take a shower like i could
see
was it like the size of that oh a little
bigger than that
would you see like longer so the
neighbors when they open their
shower window you can see the light
coming through yeah i can see the light
couldn't see any naked windows itself
blacked out um
no it just is black behind the window
like it's a glass window
but yeah it was super creepy and i was
really scared to ever open it
because the subject of a horror film
yeah you could do a lot with that
it was creepy but it was really a cute
apartment it had a built-in vanity and
everything and built-in
uh dressers um it had like this
murphy bed but they took out the bed
part and made it a built-in
bookshelf and it's really cute yeah my
first place had a built-in
like vanity and and stuff in the bedroom
but
i i never really got to fully live alone
because oh
yeah my only apartment that i had
without a boyfriend
was with me and isaac so it's still like
i still had it i never knew what it was
like
to live completely 100
alone like where you go home and like
it's just you yeah
i never i've never known what that's
like although i've never not had a pet
so i wasn't completely completely alone
because like
every time franklin was at the vet or
like he had to stay there whatever it
felt weird being home
because i did not like being alone alone
i always have to have some sort of
it helps animal energy i think i think i
did
get to experience like little tiny
snippets of what it would be
like to live alone whenever isaac would
go to his dad's so i would be for like a
weekend or something yeah
that counts oh that counts how long is
it like that
what do you mean how long were you alone
oh like a weekend yeah no i mean how
long did you live
alone yeah um a year and a half
a year and a half maybe yeah oh that's
so bad yeah yeah
so you were alone with no pets and no
roommates or anything i was alone alone
in k-town for like a year or so
ew you were almost never there i was
almost done
like nikki what sorry my only experience
like in k-town at like the apartments
where people lived alone i mean maybe it
was just
like my age at that time like young 20s
like you try to get the cheapest
apartment right i think it's scary as
[ __ ]
yeah it was scary as [ __ ] like there
were and there were like you go on the
crime thing there were just rapes
happening every day
like murders and rapes and all kinds of
[ __ ] happening all the time park like 50
miles away from your place because
if there was no parking yeah i wouldn't
want to walk around there at night so i
get it
yeah so i was there for a year by myself
but i was gone most of the time also
because i was traveling a bunch
but when i was like alone alone it was
nice i like decorated it the way i
wanted to
i could be naked as much as i wanted
like i i would just eat and then just
like put the food on the floor next to
me and clean it up the next day
you didn't have coffee i still do that
it was a brand new building
yeah right now it was a brand new
building and i was like
this is really nice like i get to just
finally be
on my own i remember you had plants and
i had plants what
yeah you took care of things yeah it was
nice wow
um and then you know people just come
over like minimum
i still just can't picture gina like
taking care of a plant
and then like i would have photo shoots
in my own place because like i can just
have photographers she's like all right
let's just shoot here
so it was cool but then like it was kind
of scary
living on your own in your 20s as just
like a woman yeah yourself
so i was like i kind of miss the feeling
of roommates
because then you're never truly alone
and you're kind of safe so after that i
moved in with two roommates um
which uh which i still have now which i
really love and i'm like in a house
house now
yeah i like your house thanks yeah so
it's like a lot
it's more roomy um so it's i think i
like it more with roommates because i
feel safer
um so that whole thing like i would
sometimes freak myself out thinking like
oh my god i'm alone and i'm a woman
like someone could just break in and i
what do i do and yeah um what helped me
was
my neighbor played their tv really loud
and it just felt like
my dad was home like he was like yeah
yeah like my family's
next door like they're someone's home
like that
i'm trying i'm trying to think that
because i have a really
loud upstairs neighbor and like the
apartment that i live in is pretty old
so there's not a lot of insulation so
you hear
everything so i'm trying to reframe it
in my mind of like
not being annoyed at how loud my
neighbors are but thinking like oh my
roommates are home
yeah because otherwise i just sit there
like [ __ ] pissed so angry
i will say upstairs neighbors are the
demon satanists
especially when they have hardwood
floors yes why
it literally sounded like elephants with
bowling balls for shoes were
walking around up there convinced that
my upstairs neighbor was a [ __ ] tap
dancer
one time my [ __ ] painting fell off a
wall because they were
so loud like rumbling so much
moving furniture constantly i remember i
was living there and like after
six months i finally heard him have sex
for the first time and then like so
like you can hear the bed squeaking and
everything and at first i was like what
the [ __ ] but then i also i was just like
when you got turned on no i was like you
know what bro i'm happy for you it's
been like six months man you know
good for you yeah get it dude no i was
such a [ __ ] with that in that one
apartment
my next door neighbor because i was
towards the end so i only had one
like sharing one wall and that dude he
would have different girls come over all
the time and
have loud ass sex and i
honestly if i was completely alone i
probably wouldn't care but the fact that
he kept waking isaac
and me yeah in the middle of the night
yeah that [ __ ] pissed me off so
bad that i i would go over and like
banging on his door i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah shut up start vacuuming your
ceiling damn that's what i do you just
vacuum your ceiling you know he was next
to me
oh back on your wall so i'm like
pounding on the wall
dude i called the cops on him after like
first seven times
of me going over there like can you
please we are sleeping it's three
o'clock in the morning my toddler's
waking up
asking what's that sound and i have to
explain to him well he's having sex
right over there
no but i'm just like come on dude it's
in the middle of the night did i ever
say anything
um he he got annoyed obviously because
obviously like he was like i'm trying to
[ __ ] yeah exactly like i understand
confrontational
yeah you really need to take me like i
need to get to that point
like a boiling point and then i'm like
that's it i've been patient enough
i've been nice enough this is what like
that's it like
you're gonna [ __ ] earn this yes you
earned it they also you don't realize
how expensive it is to live on your own
until you live on your own yeah
because bless you because you you pay
for everything yourself now you got rent
furniture toilet paper cleaning things
toothpaste
so expensive to live by yourself dish
soap yeah like cleaning things
a [ __ ] coffee if you need to like it
gets [ __ ] expensive it's annoying
you're like oh i don't even like this
[ __ ] like i don't
like to clean why do i gotta buy
cleaning supplies because like
growing up in your family's place there
was just always cleaning supplies and
also i had to learn how to get rid of
cobwebs by myself and i was so disgusted
before i lived alone i was so grossed
out by everything i would
i would never clean anything and like my
boyfriend before me
um had like he was like just crazy neat
freak and so he would clean everything
and so when i lived alone i was like oh
no what do i do i gotta clean my own
[ __ ] and you know how uh helpless you
are with cleaning things
on your own you know how helpless i am
trying to buy clothes
yes extremely helpless but also just
kind of lazy
true so uh stitch fix our favorite
stitch fix
and by the way i just i wore this
because i i wanted to be able to reveal
hey i got these pants what those are
cute
what color would you say this is like
hunter green like yeah like emerald
green i love this color of pants and
they're so soft well now they got a
little bit of
fuzz on them from this thing so we'll
cover it back up but yes i do have
stitch fix clothes in my closet thank
you very much dick stitch face
so they are a personal online shopping
styling company uh they'll bring you the
world of fashion right to your door you
don't really have to do much except take
a little quiz and say
i like these things i don't like these
things don't ever send me this
i wrote in my thing i was like stop
sending me this type of shirt with this
wood you're such a karen
she really is the stylist probably got
the thing it was like all right [ __ ]
fine
um but yes so they uh to get started set
up your profile and they'll deliver
great looks personalized just for you in
your color styles and budget you'll pay
a twenty dollar styling fee for each fix
which is credited towards anything you
keep
and you can schedule at any time you
don't have to stick with a subscription
uh you also get free shipping returns
and exchanges
stitch fix does the hard work for you
making a style effortless for everybody
including
men and kids that's great
to get started today go to stitchfix.com
mood and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's
slash stitchfix.com good for 25 off when
you keep everything in the box
stitch books.com i want to get to the
point in my life where i have a personal
sales for a kid
oh yeah well i'm sure you're smiling a
lot because you have such a
great style now check out candid candid
can help
so candid clear liners are comfortable
removable and
totally invisible so unlike braces it's
a lot easier to keep your teeth clean
it's also
just really convenient because you can
remove your aligners anytime you want to
eat
and you don't have to worry about all
that wire i used to use a water pick
when i had braces do you ever do i just
bought myself a water pigment
i've only tried it because isaac has one
too the point is you don't need one with
candy exactly that's the point
you don't need one with candid and so
with candid your treatment includes
remote modern
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan so you never have to
worry
how you're doing you'll always know
which i personally love
i love that the average candid treatment
is just six months so you'll start
seeing results
way before then and the cost is
an average 50 percent less than
invisalign so save some money too so get
ready to take the first step
towards getting your dream smile you
can't wait to show off
get started today from the comfort of
your own home with candid's risk-free
starter kit and
75 off go to candidco.com
mood use code mood that's candid
co.com mood code
mood for your risk-free starter kit and
75
off one last time candid co.com slash
mood code
mood food okay so i wanted to get a
little bit more into like the more
detailed questions and i found one that
was really interesting
um she prefers to stay anonymous okay
and her question is
i have been with my boyfriend for six
years i am 22 and he is 24. oh wow
he has a sister who is 26. wait so 12.
six
16. i guess so wow good for them
yeah look at that he also has a sister
who's 26. we all get along great and
regularly
all go out together the problem is
all three of us always go out together
like i spent my anniversary weekend with
the two of them
and i'm not okay with it wait his sister
has to show up to everything
weird okay he looks weird he won't want
to go anywhere unless she goes with us
and he always invites her whenever i try
to make plans for just the two of us
like i said we all have a great time
together but sometimes i just want
couples time i brought up in the past
and he gets really defensive and tells
me i'm
being privileged and rude yeah
is this my forever am i in a throuple
baby
break up are you serious well hold
well i i'm curious to know if she's had
a conversation with the sister
because yeah it's one thing to go to the
man and obviously he has a soft spot
with it but
maybe she could she could also have a
conversation with the sister and be like
hey
you know can you respect our own well
why is it up to her to go
piss on you for sure that's right tell
him just tell him
tell him i get that too i'm sure he
should be the very good
friend for sure um the thing is is that
if he
feels the need to constantly invite her
that means he's uncomfortable spending a
long time with you yeah
and that's the problem that's a huge
problem yeah but then
because it kind of reminds me of that
one friends episode when i think it was
yes yes she or rachel one because rachel
rachel yeah she ends up going out with
some guy and then when they go back home
it turns out that his sister is taking a
bubble bath and then she's like are you
going to join me today
the boy like the guy that rachel's going
out with and then he ends up leaving
rachel and joins the sister and
the bubble bath yeah it's just so long
like they'll have like tickle wrestle
fights
and then rachel will be like and then
rachel's like um
we should talk about your sister and the
guy goes oh god this talk again
like it's happened before this is weird
yeah i would not be okay with this
because like you know
anniversaries are like a big thing like
it's a couple's thing yeah
and for him to for him to not care about
what you want especially when you
brought it up already
that's a problem dude like that's that
just shows what he's it's going to be
like
for the rest and also for him not to not
want it to be a romantic
thing that's weird you're a young girl
you got plenty of time to get out
now get out i know it's been six years
but like think of it as an
educational relationship it was like you
learned a lot from your mother
stuck with something like that you know
you set your boundaries now
i was trying to give them the benefit of
the doubt but i'm like not for real
that's kind of weird can you imagine
when they get married the pastor's like
do you
take him and her to be your lawfully
wedded husband and sister-in-law and
they're just standing there it makes me
wonder too like how come this
this sister doesn't have anyone either
like oh yeah
she doesn't have a boyfriend joining in
and why is she so unaware like oh maybe
i should give them some alone she's
older too
yeah she should know i feel and this is
probably just because we don't have all
the details of the story so my brain's
like filling in all the gaps
but i'm like he went to his sister and
was like look i don't want to be alone
with her like i'm i don't know how to
break up six years i'm bored
stay together for that sometimes people
are too scared to break up they're like
they grew up together they got together
when they were 16. um
so they kind of kind of they're
codependent you know they don't know how
to be
alone maybe maybe you do a person that
submitted who's wasn't your anonymous
anonymous maybe you know how to build
him but maybe he doesn't maybe he's just
he'd rather be with you in a mediocre
relationship yeah well the real the real
test
is whether she can be alone or not as if
she can go ahead and back off of this
relationship because honey if you stay
you're selling yourself short yeah
you're gonna start you know
having these codependent issues if you
don't already and also there's
like kind of gaslighting for him to get
totally yeah
yeah yeah you're crazy and privileged
that's not normal
no you're not that's not you being
privileged or
that's not crazy or privileged at all
that's totally normal out of the box
response
yeah privileged in what way is that a
privilege yeah
yeah to not to want to be alone with
your boyfriend yeah i don't think that's
a privilege
i'm like is she there when they're
having sex too like what the [ __ ] like
he probably
on his phone he like calls her and just
leaves the phone on the board
yeah they're two years apart right
because he's 24.
she's 22. the sister is 26 and the
sister's 26. she's a really close age
she's older she should have her own life
and why is she hanging out with her
little
brother all the time so weird right girl
go outside get a boyfriend
i don't like it and yeah like like they
said
the way he responded to your the way you
approached it because i'm sure you
approached it multiple times normally
the way that he responded to it is a
huge red flag
to make you feel like that because that
means he's trying to hide something
probably he's trying to make it
dump it on you he knows it's wrong also
just even the fact that you've been with
him from 16 to 22
i kind of feel like okay you've gone
through this relationship you've
probably learned a lot
this is probably not going to last your
whole life anyway so don't drag it out
like you know at this point it's time to
like get a different
a different yeah either be alone for a
little while because you know from 16 to
22 you've always been with someone
and their sister so you don't know how
to be alone already and then
you're gonna need to like a new adult
relationship at some point this guy's
not it
no i'm sure he's not it just on that one
thing
dating only child from now
yeah and like you're young enough right
now that it's not
too late to start over and date someone
new yeah you guys have been together for
a long time but you're still so young
yeah so there's there's plenty of cool
people out there who do not have
siblings
or are not umbilically tied to their
siblings still that's [ __ ] weird dude
um biblically i really do i really
i'm so curious to know what would happen
if she were to ask the sister though
yeah the sister would be like no i think
the brother
told the sister to hey have my back have
my back
like i think she's just trying to be a
good older sister i mean that's just me
projecting but if she was being a good
older sister and she would tell
like help her out maybe he's not
emotional or maybe she's not emotionally
immature enough to
do it that way she's trying to help
people stay and release a mess that they
don't need a hot mess
what can you do so i hope that advice
helped you personally we're not for this
relationship um
sorry so i'm sorry all right
moving on to the next person uh also an
anonymous imagine it's the same person
i just had an idea i feel like we should
do this whole thing of like should i
stay or should i go and then we'll all
vote and be like
or not because you need a panel of women
to tell you yeah
and we'll ask well you guys can ask us
and we all look crazy
we're very qualified yeah certified
happy relationship
super healthy i've never had
relationship problems in our life we
know we know well
all right the next question is also
anonymous uh she says hey
i listen to every podcast you put out
thank you thanks so much
one question i haven't seen addressed
too often is have you ever experienced
retroactive jealousy where you are
jealous of your partner's past
this was an interesting one that i read
a few months into my relationship with
my partner i was obsessive about asking
about his previous relationship even
stalking his ex's facebook page
i even got jealous knowing they had sex
on the bed he slept on
so we switched mattresses with another
one of the house oh honey whenever
things that were mentioned that reminded
me of her or we found things of hers he
forgot he had i would spiral down
retroactive jealousy
luckily it's been over six months since
i felt like that we've been dating over
a year and a half now and i can say that
i overcame my jealousy
by being a better me and more confident
and not allowing myself to give
energy to someone who is in the past
yeah have you experienced this yeah
that's definitely coming from a place of
insecurity
yourself i think it's and i think it's
okay to have
feelings like that like you're only
human like you you know you're picturing
your partner with some other girl is not
fun especially if you know
they used to have sex and they used he
used to love her or whatever it's not
fun it's really rude nikki
but i think it's really rude that my
significant other found anyone else
attractive before well my significant
others are all virgins and they've
never had anyone before me so like you
guys are so healthy
no absolutely like it's so gross that
other people would like other people
it's so gross yeah oh how what a monster
right but i think the way that you
express it is the
the deal breaker because you don't want
to
let that start uh causing resentment in
your relationship when it's not
it's not anyone's fault that you have
history you know there's like everyone
has
it's his fault let's be honest here it's
kind of history it is his fault
how dare he date before well actually
with with uh my first
serious relationship okay so
during that relationship he would
constantly bring up his ex
and all constantly saying that that's
not good yeah so that's triggering
exactly so then every time we listen
we'd listen to like for example shade
was like a huge thing with the two of
them
i love her sorry go ahead so then i know
i love
you hashtag queen for a while though it
was like kind of like a sore spot for me
any time it came on cause they were it
would like trigger me for those feelings
but now i don't give a [ __ ] i [ __ ]
love shoddy yeah but anyway so in that
time
i was 16 17 and just constantly hearing
him like reminisce of his relationship
with
her oh no what the [ __ ]
he was he would all the time and he'd be
driving he'd be like oh yeah that's
where we had our first
date what the [ __ ] no how did you stay
with this guy
because my mom was going through a lot
of stuff at home i was going through a
lot of traffic at home i was trying to
get away from my house literally like
abusive
home and and this was like my outlet
like
out of my house that's why i put up with
so much yeah but yeah so then that would
like he would constantly say all those
things and he would also compare me to
her a lot and say like oh
like if we would have be having an
intimate moment he'd be like oh she used
to make that look too
bro yeah you can get the [ __ ] out of my
house
so then it got to the point where i
started feeling like
jealousy and anger towards her even
though obviously
that's totally valid yeah
so then during that time myspace was a
big thing so
like i remember trying to look her up
and seeing like what she looked like and
i'm like oh [ __ ]
we do kind of look a little bit similar
and
and then guess what they got back
together didn't they no
he would still message her he would send
her photos of me and tell her how
much prettier she was than me oh he has
issues bro
wow
well they also had like a crazy history
i'm not gonna get into it but like they
yeah it just it really matters
you were like
you're not happy in your your new
relationship if you keep on
contacting your ex be like look i'm so
much better than you she's so much
better looking no that didn't open just
one he was saying that
she was better than tiff yeah look how
my new girl's way better than you look
at her look she's better than you
no no she's saying that she yeah she's
better than you
yeah talk about people yeah [ __ ] yeah
right
and then not just that but then another
boyfriend how did you find this out by
the way oh because during like
okay this he gave me so many red flags
and and
at that point like i was already into
deep tiff and so
i was like well i had this like crazy
insecurity inside because of all these
things and so i would look and i would
look up his myspace and i would see his
messages
that's how i found out that they were
messaging each other and
that was and then it wasn't just a one
time like i actually put up with it
for quite some time and she would
entertain it um not really because she
had moved on already
right she had moved on she had her own i
was like why is so obsessed with me
yeah i want to know dude i'm sorry that
was against
eminem and we should not say that oh we
blasphemed
somehow i found her number i think he
had it saved on her his phone
so oh this is so ugly and i'm disgusted
but you got to learn i would call her
and like just hear her voice
just hear her voice you both were
obsessed with her i wasn't like
he got her obsessed with yeah he
implanted it it's because like how i got
her into animal crossing yeah
and then you left me alone no but like
it just got to the point where i needed
to
compare i'm like how how is she
different than me
and i called her maybe twice and she
like i wouldn't say anything and she's
just like
hello
[Laughter]
yeah but then the boyfriend like a few
boyfriends after
like he that dude like in the beginning
when we were
getting together like i found out that
he was messaging his ex and saying he
missed her and i was just like
triggers up with these dudes so
triggered i mean i know what's up with
me that they're doing those guys oh my
god yeah there's a there's a term for
that it's called a pick me girl
like you'll do anything just to pick me
yeah like i'll compete with other women
just pick everything
please pick me well so i had a bit of a
pick me
uh situation just like yours because
what i think we talked about this on the
uh and back in the haybitch days where
um i had an
ex that he was like on drugs and he kept
going back to this other girl oh yeah
like slit her tires so i guess the only
time that i've been jealous is it's yeah
it's like when the guy
has like brought her into my [ __ ]
space yeah
wait we're together what the [ __ ] are
you doing with her and then i mean
immediately as soon as a guy
says anything about his ex in any sort
of way that's like infringing on our
relationship a meat that's a grounds for
immediate [ __ ]
dismissal this [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
unhealthy
you know what else is unhealthy not
taking vitamins thank you jess
thank you if if relationships can take
vitamins you know what they would take
they would take care of because those
are taking care of yourself girl
and care of is a wellness brand that
makes it easy to maintain your health
goal with a customized vitamin plan
that helps you feel your best today and
support you long term so
care of what you do is you go online and
then you tell them what problems you
have
i can't sleep so many problems i have no
energy my skin
is messed up utis and then care of will
put together a custom
vitamin packet for you to take every
single day and it's just like humidity
chlamydia
so much anxiety anxiety
they just send her an email [ __ ] you
need antibiotics
sorry this is not a doctor's office it's
just
wellness so so you go you take a cute
quiz and they make these convenient
daily packs that are perfect for
on-the-go lifestyles
has your name on it too it does have
your name on it and it has like a quote
of the day
or like a fact of the day which is
really cute they also have yummy protein
powders that are made of real
ingredients you can recognize like
organic cocoa and pink himalayan sea
salt
um and the cool thing is the packaging
is completely biodegradable
i like this so much that i bought this
with my own money i still have it at
home because this is the one thing that
i do to keep myself healthy yeah we only
get the first one for free and then we
keep buying them because yeah
addicting yeah and it's just it just
looks cool like i just feel cool like
vitamin packet i'm so rich i like things
that like are it's just like it's put
together
it's easy yeah um so the
quiz is super fun and easy it's so cute
and uh the individual packets are just
so awesome to have it's just so easy to
take every day you just put them in your
purse
take them later and then you get to
choose like do you like taking like
would you rather take a bunch of small
pills or like a
fewer pills but bigger i can take a
bunch of small pills so i just have like
a mouthful like eight pills a day
i like to pretend that i'm a druggie um
so cool but a healthy one i'm
high on health you know and now
uh for 50 off your first care of order
go to take care of
calm and enter the code big mood 50.
that's that's a lot that's that's
50 off dude 50
what more do you need to be healthy to
be a healthy druggie
bro again for 50 off your first caro of
order go to take care of
calm and enter the code big mood 50.
yeah
put it inside you and once you got
vitamins in your hair and your hair is
growing all lush and thick and
sexy you're going to want to take care
of that hair and how you take care of it
is with function of beauty what i love
well first of all i just love function
of beauty
because uh they do customized uh what's
it called like foreign we just love
custom everything
you do because you know when you go and
buy a generic thing you're like how come
it worked for her but didn't work for me
like i want
i want my hair to look like hers we
don't have the same hair
we don't need the same shampoo so
function of beauty is hair care that's
formulated specifically for you no
matter how
what your hair type is how it's how
coarse it is how thin it is how
curly straight or whatever you're going
to tell them all that [ __ ] you give them
all the details
and they're going to create a shampoo
conditioner and treatments to fit your
unique needs
how unique you ask well function of
beauty has over 54
trillion possible ingredient
combinations to make sure your formula
is as neat as unique as you i can't even
that's not even a real number yeah that
number it's insane
how they met that i don't know a lot
computers had to do it i think
i also like that they give you um you
get to pick the scent i'm right now i'm
i'm on i used to have eucalyptus but now
i'm on lavender i just like those
stress-free scents and uh you get to
pick the color
and then you get to put your name on the
bottle absolutely like we like to see it
okay
we love it we love it so what are you
waiting for go to functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your four part hair
profile quiz and save 20
on your first order go to
functionofbeauty.com
big mood for twenty percent off and let
them know that you heard about it from
our show
that's function and beauty dot com slash
big mood
get it girls so what was i talking about
my douchebag [ __ ] ex
right retroactive jealousy
this dick head i don't care i hope
you're watching
thank you guys [ __ ] you guys um
okay so he would gaslight the [ __ ] out
of me all the time it was a very like
emotionally
abusive relationship it was the
narcissist codependently right okay
so um he had a book of all of his
exes all of their names and check marks
next to them
i later found um a a
file on his computer with all of them
topless some of them sociopathic
yeah like trophies yeah what the [ __ ]
that's psychopathic behavior
yes sleepy creepy i think he's
associated about that
yes some yeah and then i or eventually i
found a picture of me topless and sleepy
because i don't take topics
i do not take them i don't take nudes i
don't do any i don't she's a liar i have
a bunch of ben mommy
your eyes only okay um but yeah so this
guy would take like
basically like trophy pictures and he
had all of their names listed and stuff
and then um sometimes i would see like
he would
get a text and like he'd like kind of be
like hiding about it
and i would look at it i could see like
names and i knew their names because i
saw that list before
or sometimes he would be like i'm gonna
go to dinner with this one girl my
friend blah blah and he really like
conditioned me to believe like
you know uh they're just friends and
once like we're broken up they're
like we're friends friends friends but
he was friends friends with all of his
exes
and would constantly go to dinner with
them but he would never take me out to
dinner and he would always say that he
didn't have money to go out to dinner or
whatever
he didn't have money to go get drinks or
whatever you can't go with your ex what
the [ __ ]
i know and then he would be like no but
i haven't seen them in so long so it's
like a special thing and i'm like oh i'm
so mad
i'm so bad yeah i'm so mad and then he
would get mad at me if i brought it up
if i was
going crazy i would bring it up so
gently right because i wanted him
i wanted him to think i was cool so bad
that's a narcissistic co-dependency
yes yeah because he made me think like
people that
are not cool with people hanging out
with their exes have insecurities and
like
all kinds of stuff so i wanted to be
like hey you know i just you know um
like it's
totally fine if you guys meet up but i
just you know felt like maybe we should
go out sometime too and it was always
like that
yeah and he would make me feel so bad
about bringing up his exes
and uh then one time i wanted trash by
the way
yeah i mean there's so many stories oh
so many of them but anyway
um oh one time he called me his ex's
name like
right after sex like he was like
give me all this uh jennifer that's not
her name but like yeah
and she said her name and cuddled me i
would immediately i would start swinging
nope
we're swinging we're swinging just [ __ ]
that dude oh my god trying to catch a
case over a waste of space
oh and then um also like you tiff after
a while i was going [ __ ] crazy
and i read his old journal like he kept
his journal on
a shelf and like crazy so it was like
yeah it was journals
he's been really good at hiding things
honestly no he's not um
he's like hiding in plain sight kind of
personally so blatantly
exactly because that's just how arrogant
they are that they're like i'm gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] i want i could get
away with it yeah i'll wiggle myself out
of it somehow with my
characters because women are like kind
of naturally like
more forgiving like we're taught to be
like oh you know
stand by your man kind of stuff like
even just subtly like even if your mom
never said that
like there's just subtle things where
we're like make everything [ __ ] okay
yeah just to keep the manner right or
die that's like yeah right or die super
hard and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he would even tell me
things like um i'll get to the journal
entry but
he would even tell me things like um
that he used to work at a strip club
as a bus boy and the strippers were so
dumb
that he would always call them hun and
like that's the only way that he could
get them to understand things he'd be
like
han yeah exactly he told me that he
would do this
and then when i would bring up [ __ ] he
would go hun
i just started putting pieces together i
was like this guy thinks i'm [ __ ]
stupid and so i read his journal entries
and he would write entries of
how he would gaslight his girlfriend's
like yeah and then i told her
this this and this and she actually
thought my aunt died and then uh yeah
and then it sounds like a reddit post on
like slash
[ __ ] insults or whatever they're
saying so he gave away like all of his
manipulation techniques he's like i
barely got away with the damage control
on that one
oh no bro i hope this guy gets
absolutely sh
like just she deserves to be run over by
a seminar absolutely awful
sure and if you're watching you know who
i'm talking about [ __ ] you guys
no thank you guys for your time up these
stories right we're talking about when
we got jealous it's because the guy
was like doing something so i'm kind of
wondering honey was there anything
going on or that's what i wanted to know
too but i remember her saying something
like she
was just out of the blue in it just out
of the blue
like because why would she if it's
giving her a little bit more benefit of
the dalai lama
it has never failed me that's how i
found out one of my exes
was saving a collection of his ex's
panties oh
so you bring up those like yeah
this [ __ ] had a collection of
used panties
it was [ __ ] disgusting
why are some men why they're so why are
men why
are men men but yeah so i guess if he's
done literally nothing wrong i mean it
is obviously possible for her to just
have self-esteem issues
and i'm glad that she's apparently
worked through them but she's still kind
of thinking about it right now six
months later so that worries me a little
bit
here's the thing i got with steve steve
was the next relationship
after this guy right like i love him
there was still like oh the
it's like the carry-over yeah from so
any little thing i was like is that
another
thing you know and self-preserved
preservation so
preservation like of course so there was
definitely stuff stuff
that was my fault that um in steve and
i's relationship that it was just
projections of
that old relationship that's scary
though because like when you're the type
of person that has been through a bunch
of traumatic relationships then you'll
attract
kind of the same piece of [ __ ] type of
guy again so then you're like oh is it
just
me but it's like no you're you're
cycling the scent so luckily steve was
like that was that was after i had like
been like i'm not settling anymore
this is the type of guy he does any red
flags but
yeah he he didn't exhibit any red flags
i just
was so like
old stuff and then he was also
projecting old stuff from his really old
relationship onto me
but i did get jealous at some of his
stories um i wouldn't
get mad at him but it was just
internalized jealousy at some of his
stories because
um he was talking about how not his
previous ex with the ex before her
um he was like obsessed with her and he
like she could do no wrong and she was a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like she like spent 25 grand on his
credit card and never paid
like he was in debt because of her and
um he was trying to pay for her college
and she
spent the money on like shopping and
itunes and all kinds of stuff and he was
still like so obsessed with her just
wanted to take care of her like all this
stuff
and um i was like damn like and he's
like i will never do that again i will
never put a woman on a pedestal ever
again
i will never do that a liar he's got you
on youtube
but i deserve it okay you're a good
person
you deserve a good pedestal but yeah at
that time he was very like
never again and i was like she got to be
ordered
yeah i feel like that's a natural
reaction yeah but i never i never told
him that i was never like it never
became a fight or anything
you know what it does like let's bring
up that uh what would she call it
retroactive retroactive jealousy
jealousy
i had no idea what the word by the way
yeah term yeah so
sometimes like whenever that springs up
now a day well actually it hasn't
happened in years but
with casey like being with casey is
because he would
talk about a time and then think it was
me but it was his ex
and i'm like oh i love the wrong
girlfriend what happened because
wrong [ __ ] happens all the time that's
super annoying but i've also done that
in dating because like i'll be dating
like three or four not sleeping with at
the same time but i'll be like going on
well before [ __ ] quarantine let me
just qualify this before quarantine i
was going on a [ __ ] ton of dates and
like i would
be at with one guy on a date and i'd be
like oh and you you liked video games
right and he's like wait no and i'm like
oh yeah
getting all my [ __ ] mixed up yeah so i
was really careful with that but then
ever since like or like whenever
casey started doing it then i would i
would be
less careful so then sometimes like i'll
bring up a situation he'd be like that
was
wrong boyfriend and oh you're like how
does it feel
put it back in his face it's so vengeful
well she did say it was the first like
six months or whatever right
so i might have carried over to be
honest yeah carry over
like low self-esteem because i think
that first year it is just like flushing
out a lot of the old and like learning
to trust your new favorite haven't spent
time enough time single between yourself
yes
exactly which is what i'm forcing myself
to do now is to actually spend
a lot more time single not dating not
bringing in more baggage with every new
guy
in between so yeah maybe that's she just
needed more time
cleanse it out yeah i think they said
you need
half the time of your old relationship
that's 2.5 years for me yeah
well i'm already one year in yeah so
nice oh
i don't know if i'm gonna wait another
like another year and a half to try
but at least maybe another 60 yeah i
mean i don't i don't even think you need
you don't need to wait like you know if
you find the right guy you don't even
force yourself to wait but
like it kind of to flush the rest out
like i feel like i did need a couple
more months yeah
of mine because i was together with my
ex for two years and then
i got with steve like eight months after
the breakup and so there was there were
a few overlapping months where it just
wasn't completely flushed out yeah
i feel that yeah yeah maybe she like in
her previous relationship it was
the really really toxic word she just
brought her baggage in
so in conclusion men are trash oh
good men are just they're scared because
they've been with trash women you know
and so they're scared too yeah
i'm on that tip right now i'm like not
only ten percent are kings and the rest
are [ __ ]
oh chester trash it might be the same
for women too though
it could be yeah because i've heard a
lot of horror stories from guy friends
about girlfriends
or like even bridezilla stories is like
so much more common than not
and i do know a lot of trash women my
wedding photographer told me i was the
chillest bride he's ever seen in his
life he's like
you're the only person i've ever
photographed for that didn't like turn
it into a show
like it wasn't like their show their day
i was like i don't know i just
i never had expectations for a wedding
so it just seemed like it was a birthday
party
like and in conclusion women are insane
all right
we like to deal
keep telling yourself that so you stay
single for six months yeah
that's what i gotta do all right next
question is from amish asian
uh is that possible nothing no how do
you use a rice cleaner
but right i've never seen wait
i've only seen white amish people yes
are there any other
no why would there be maybe they got
adopted or like
yeah or they went into the they wanted
they converted they converted
naturally non-white right quakers i mean
they got dragged in somehow if i ever
meet an asian amish i might lose my mind
yeah that's awesome weird that is cool
yeah they try to grow the beard but it's
just all patchy it doesn't work
it's like it's like a lollipop you
dropped on the carpet
beer doesn't connect you can't be true
amish bye
amish asian asked how do you know when a
compromise between your significant
other is fair
oh that's a great question that is a
good question if you feel satisfied
i think you know like both parties if
both parties feel satisfied
like it's not like going against your
morals yeah right i asked myself like
am i okay with this like will i be okay
with this a week from now a month
yeah you have to future protect that
[ __ ] like 10 years from now yeah am i
okay with this decision we made
right will it build resentment exactly i
think that's the major
major thing that couples go through is
they don't realize how much resentment
they've been building until it's too
late
so anytime you feel a little bit of
resentment you need to nip that [ __ ] in
the bud like you need to like
this ain't working we need to reform out
our plan can we think of some examples
of like a healthy compromise versus a
non-healthy compromise
like i i like for for maybe like oh well
maybe he likes to watch tv at night
or in the bedroom or she likes quiet
time at night so what should we do
a healthy compromise is he puts on
headphones or he goes and watch tv
downstairs
or she goes and reads in another room if
she wants to for quiet time that's a
healthy or they do like a time limit on
it like maybe
he gets an hour yeah yeah like it can't
be a compromise like
okay well um i get to cheat on you every
two or three months i get to hang out i
get to have dinner with my ex-girlfriend
like i'll compromise that once a week
but once a month or so wow like that's
that's not a healthy compromise i'll
give you an
unhealthy compromise same dick bag um
same [ __ ] you guys the same dick bag
yeah they were calling
one of them a dick now i was like what
did i miss
like wow nikki that was like this
emotionally manipulative
[ __ ] god i hope i meet this guy one
day a new one right now i hope i don't
he uh i don't know which camera he would
have a problem texting me back
like he would never text me back right
away like and he would text me back at
like four in the morning or some [ __ ] it
was getting really
annoying because we would make plans and
then he would not show up
and then he would text like at three in
the morning like oh yeah he fell asleep
or whatever the [ __ ]
and i'm like cool i threw your tacos in
the trash can because i made tacos for
us
i was so pissed but anyway um it got to
be a real problem where i was like
but again i wanted to be cool and chill
right so i was like hey
so like um it really makes me sad when
you like don't text me back right away
and like um
or like even like within a reasonable
amount of time and like i always respond
to your text and blah blah
so he was like all right if you
shave all of your hair off your vagina
um because he didn't like the landing
strip look i guess
even though it was very trim just let
you know um he
he wanted he's like if you make it like
really clean shaved every day
i'll text you back immediately and i
agreed to this [ __ ]
and i like made sure like everything's
important
so early 20s just she had to learn a lot
she just had to learn a lot it was the
school of hard knocks for her and she
learned
and he still didn't text background that
guy
honestly electric chair electric
terrible human i hate him
yeah and that's a shitty thing because
you're you're taught like you know like
you know
don't don't cause any drama you know
just talk it out bubble ball and like
or as a girl you should be chill or
whatever and yeah like you kind of learn
that when you're young and you're kind
of
you think that way when you're young
yeah but once you get older
like now like in your 30s you don't have
time for that [ __ ] you're like hey this
bothers me and we need to fix this or
this is going to be a [ __ ] problem
and we're going to talk about it i will
say though i do like my
a clean shaven [ __ ] yeah that's fine
like i do i did
she was manipulative when you want to do
it on your own on my own i wanted to
choose to do this
yeah she doesn't know because she
manipulated to do it
not that guy [ __ ] do it for me i
think
a lot of times like your body will tell
you what's right or wrong and then a lot
of times women will ignore what your
body's telling you
and try to like make excuses you know
rationalize
shitty behavior but if you if you need
to compromise on something and you don't
feel unsettled or you don't feel
like your stomach doesn't feel good
about it oh i hate that feeling and i
know that feeling so well i've
overlooked that feeling and
every single time i've had it i've
regretted it
so it's no good god i hope that guy's
balls fall off dude you know what a
horrible
holy [ __ ] he deserves that you know that
guy that got his dick
like it fell off and he had to regrow it
on his arm
he deserves that his dick to like just
get regularly
he can't regrow it yeah there's no
there's no growth i hope that happens
but the only place that's willing to
regrow it back is in the middle of his
[ __ ] forehead
exactly yeah because he has a [ __ ]
on that note
and on that note on that note say no to
[ __ ] thank you guys so much for
watching
um thanks for asking questions make sure
you guys follow us on instagram because
this is where we ask you guys
we didn't call it a big-ass question i
did i said it no one heard me
um so make sure you guys follow call it
big ask mood please
because we will be prompting you guys to
ask us questions for big ask mood
uh what did we learn today uh don't be a
dick bag don't settle
don't settle don't don't rationalize
shitty behaviors
don't be a third wheel sister that's
[ __ ] weird that's weird
shave your vagina smooth only if you
want if you want to i want you one
choice not by force
by choice not by force not by an a bad
compromise don't compromise your
vaginal hair values yeah and uh i would
like to leave off with
a word of wisdom um whoever that guy is
that nikki was talking about i swear to
god i hope
your butthole gets spread open so far
that i can see through your [ __ ]
throats
go inside out all right i love you
thanks guys thanks for watching give us
a thumbs up
like our video subscribe peace out peace
out